we're in the still in the trenches and
not really clear on where that's gonna
go the things I'm seeing in the hospital
this is really no joke and I've never
seen anything like it right now I have
so much to offer them but you don't know
how it's gonna be in next 2-3 weeks in
the last couple of weeks the number of
coronavirus patients has increased
exponentially to now over 400,000
confirmed cases in the United States we
contacted physicians in Illinois New
York and California and to hear their
perspectives but since things are
evolving so quickly we spoke to them
over the course of three days here are
their Diaries this is day number one
this is day 1 day 1 in the fight against
corona virus well we had our first
patient on the floor died which was
really sad
it's tough what we're going through that
interaction with you know the doctor who
was taking care of that patient and you
know he just kind of looked at me
incredulous and he's just like you know
I knew it was possible that was gonna
happen but it just happened so fast
there isn't necessarily set protocols
cuz no one knows how to deal with the
pandemic so we're really figuring a lot
of stuff out on the fly patients today
had mostly routine chronic medical
issues luckily today was not like three
days ago when we had our first highly
suspected Kovac 19 patient the greatest
challenge was seeing these two patients
one of them was sickly 64 year old
female and the other one was a 26 year
old young gentleman autumn had similar
symptoms you're a little tough to manage
just because you're understaffed today
not to group who showed up we're in the
still in the trenches and not really
clear on where that's gonna go we
evolved day to day we evolved our tower
it's been such a challenge to keep up
with the ever-changing recommendations
and even sometimes confusion and
conflicting recommendations we're just
not resourced appropriately for
something like this and right now it's
definitely been an uphill battle she's
you know who call
and this this 26 year old squad coughing
quite a bit I had about two guns each
time I'm going to see him haven't seen
before time so you about eight gallons
you've got about eight masks got eight
pairs of gloves it's very easy to run
out all these equipment if you have
whether it's masks what is defend to
leaders and ritas kneazle candless to
give them oxygen I think the next
challenge we're going to address is the
search that's gonna be coming in the
next couple of days or the biggest
challenges is try to calm yourself in
patients who come in because almost
everyone is and it is it's nervous
you're the captain of the ship so to
speak so you have to really have your
whole composure there you have three be
not getting nervous at all the one word
that seemed to resonate and seem to be
common commonly expressed by most of our
team was abandonment neglect isolation
the rates of death second increase we
know that we know that from Seattle
getting prepared for that is a little
scary because we're not really quite
sure how much equipment we have right
now I have so much to offer them but you
don't know how it's gonna be in the next
two three weeks so when you think about
that it's a little depressing we're
rationing our tests so that means that
they're not enough what I have heard
from the from just the phone
conversations with health state
officials is that the labs just can't
keep up with Adam and the testing demand
we really need to emphasize social
distancing just because we have to limit
the spread be smart and recognize that
this is now a public health issue and we
need to act collectively
this is day two there's been a search
for our city of covet cases and some
more parodies to some people who died
from it he continued to fight the fight
here in the trenches the I see yous are
getting really full initially we had put
all patients who are very severe in the
cardiac ICU but now that's completely
full they've moved all patients out of
the surgical and medical ICU and created
a makeshift ICU and now those ICUs are
being prepped for coronavirus overflow
patients I have never encountered a
situation where you've had to create
intensive care units on the fly we the
high notes show rate today so we had a
lot of people who just didn't come we
converted a lot of our visits to phone
consults on the good side of things the
Health and Human Service Department has
waived HIPAA requirements so we could
pretty much use Skype FaceTime to do a
video visit for me it's a challenge to
tell people to be in the front line and
I as the chief medical officer of my
group feel very responsible for people
and if I can't protect my people or my
providers it does present itself as an
ethical dilemma to me to tell them to go
see patients and they don't have the
right protection definitely one of my
little moments other than when I was
told that we don't have a no nurses tool
the night shift some nurses had call in
sick and we had a ratio of about 6
patients to one nurse which is which is
actually pretty high in a developed
country you expect to have supplies you
expect to have a system and our system
is just inadequate we've attended
several calls where they've told us to
reuse our protective masks today it was
kind of nuts but we were taking care of
one patient who suddenly developed a
cardiac arrhythmia out of nowhere he
obviously had coronavirus and while
we're getting in the process of putting
pacer pads on him another patient starts
to fall apart and they had to
to bait that patient on the other side
of the floor and you're just kind of
looking like how many shoes can drop all
at once
we've got to find other ways to work
better and smarter and we configure how
we're doing care so that we're not
burning ourselves out too quickly and
we've got to be able to sustain the
system
you know the ER is doing a better job of
admitting only patients whoo-hoo there's
a lot of concern by just the numbers
keep growing we have to really protect
ourselves I think my anxiety and stress
level rises when I go to see patients
the things I'm seeing in the hospital
this is really no joke and I've never
see anything like it we really need to
spend some time and learn from countries
where they've managed to rapidly control
and Corral the virus and the spread and
pushing back a little bit on the
expectations of health care providers
and clinical support staff I think we
need to speak up I think we need to find
ways where we get resources as a
developed country would be expected to
deliver upon and so I often wonder with
all this money that's being infused from
the feds and at the state level how much
of that is going into assuring that we
are actually increasing the supply of
personal protective equipment this is
day three of going antiviral and we had
another case of cofee infection in our
clinic staff now seems more apprehensive
not that we're seeing another case
understandably so the volunteer in 80
was low this is partly because of the
stay at home order that was issued by
the governor about two days ago so
people sit at home what he did for us
was give us more time to recuperate
arrange for things Orange our isolations
get more equipment in many of us feel
very scrambled big
everything is changing constantly can't
keep up with the guidelines can't keep
up with the confusion around doing phone
consults can't keep up with the
constantly changing testing every minute
was accounted for every minute was
talking to people every single minute
you know not even a chance to go to the
bathroom the greatest challenge of today
was keeping providers motivated to stay
in place and not panic
was keeping them focused on the fact
that we need to be here to support what
we expect will be in a surge the
greatest challenge today was probably a
surge of patients I received between
11:30 and noon received about five
patients all the patients had similar
symptoms as coronavirus patients they
came with fever chills cough runny nose
and two of nationally had shortness of
breath so it is an issue because we have
only two isolation rooms in the ER and
we can only accommodate two of those
patients at one time as far as the
situation in the hospital it's it's
definitely getting crazier our census is
of patients who either have corona virus
or who are suspected of you know has
jumped from I think it was what six
middled last week to around 85 today
existing ICUs are now only four
coronavirus patients which is nuts I've
never seen anything like it and then on
the floor patients are just falling
apart
kind of left and right it's definitely
gotten real and it's progressed faster
than I thought it would I knew it would
be quick but nothing really can prepare
you for it until you actually see it we
need to be concerned about how are we
going to treat us sick patients if we go
out to three sick patients one time
and I use of my isolation rooms what are
we going to be the other two or three
patients who are actually sick every
time I send someone out I get two more
back patients on the floor aren't
getting better as fast as I hope and
sometimes they're even getting worse
patients are presenting in ways that I
can't expect they're having
complications I don't foresee it's
somewhat inevitable that we are going to
see a large rise in cases we're going to
see possibly positive cases in our own
facility possibly employees as more and
more of the hospital becomes full of
coronavirus patients how do you keep the
virus from spreading internally I think
I've resigned myself to the fact that at
some point I'll get sick I'm just trying
to hold on for as long as I can until we
get this under control because right now
we just need bodies take care of all
these patients don't go to the doctor
call your doctor call your provider find
out if you need to be there you know the
concepts of social isolation really
preventive measures hand-washing being
cognizant if you're sick to stay away
from others taking good care of yourself
because um less we get this under
control it's going to just deplete the
resources we have so please everyone be
safe to carry yourself and and take this
seriously
you